in the 1920s and up through the 1950s
Hollywood had a particular way of
talking come around about No what are
you doing up there that person anyhow
book cover really really it was called
the Mid Atlantic or transatlantic accent
but we don't speak like that anymore
so what happened to know why it
disappeared
we need a little history the accent is
sort of a British American hybrid
linguistically speaking it has three
main tenants one drop the are like
mother and father to emphasize the tea
like raita and winter and three soften
her vowels like dogs and call and this
accent was acquired so there's no line
tracing it back through history some
believe it came out of early radio when
bass tones were difficult to hear but
many attribute its popularity to write
or Edith Skinner she actually wrote a
book called speak with distinction which
was the book to help you learn the
accent either way it was a language for
the American upper class people like FDR
Katharine Hepburn Cary Grant they all
used it but after World War two the
accent dwindled in popularity with a
growing middle class and aristocratic
accent was no longer fashionable as for
Hollywood acting methods changed and the
accent was just too fake so it
disappeared mostly if you've ever seen
the show Frasier Niles and Frasier spoke
with an updated mid-atlantic accent the
woman I love lovely
[Music]
Aereo my name is Tammy and I'm from
dolly farms originally from Atlanta
Georgia from Sydney Australia
London England Moscow Russia there's
been a lot more but those loans are
coming to mind my name is Sammy grant
I'm a dialect coach and I'm legally
blind
[Music]
a dialect coach is someone who teaches
actors accents I can do accents from
around the world I don't really even
have a count anymore because I've taught
so many I mostly work for this stage
I've started dabbling and television one
of the reasons I think that I took to
voice work and dialect work is because
I'm more in tune with hearing so people
are always like oh you a peyten hearing
I don't like that phrase because it
sounds like we have like superhero
hearing like we're daredevil or
something hello you're just like
daredevil no but I do have more attuned
hearing I use my hearing more than a
sighted person because I have to well
the London accent placement is really
important so placements like really four
words in the mouth so there's the
southern accent that lacks they are the
Australian accent quite different than
the British accent so they don't really
say like ba little more like butter
transatlantic accent is very dramatic
it's what you hear in those old time
movies it's kind of like a well I don't
know is it we're gonna love me well I
just want to know of me what if I'm too
expressive maybe he won't I don't know
what hurts next if you want to sort to
feel like you swallow something nickels
immense this is a very stereotype but
like the Jewish New York mother this is
what I do a lot with my friends you know
kind of like the why don't you cool on
me you know I I sit around away Thea
calls all day and you never call me I
don't mind it's okay
yeah just whatever I just paid for your
college tuition it's okay it's a pretty
in-depth process teaching someone an
accent I get sent this script and I try
to gather everything I can so that goes
much beyond just where does this take
place
it also factors in time period and
education level class level and I also
think about the gender of my character
and then I talk with the director I'm
just sort of you know touch base on
their concept for the voice of the show
and then I kind of go on a hunt for
authentic speakers once I've gathered
all that information I present it to the
actor
we're now surrounded by so many voices
that are emotionless you know by these
automated voices that sound very fake
works like I'd love to help you I'm a
computer that's here to help you with
whatever you want all the time I love
meeting new people and hearing their
voices I you know immediately go into
dialect coach mode and I want to sort of
imitate them I just want to like
experience their voice and experience
what their vocalizing
[Music]
my name is Yanni psycho Noma from Greece
and I speak their little languages
Russian Portuguese Norwegian Turkey be
honest is what we call a hyper polyglot
it means he can speak a lot of languages
by the time I was 20 I had already
learned some 15 languages and when I
moved to Brussels and started my career
or the EU institutions I added more
official EU languages see the thing is I
honest he's a quick learner i Spencer no
idea is for not mm mama
Ishita thermicon lang she is he how why
call you yen this doesn't happen by just
sitting at home and studying now no
clarity no I K viajar contra Costa Rica
Tata con la gente netted Lamia
procrastination no it is iike to any
metal Jonnie Jonnie [ __ ] till redneck :
muck a post so you desire veramente to
the quest a lingua con in economy
ecology only Giorno the world is a big
place with different cultures and yes
different languages a Clifton leavening
murder inspiration in Italian and meter
Mari mental I speak to my husband in
polish Polish polish I dream in all
kinds of languages targeted Solanki
share please difficult on the not
reverse the mold Willy
before we go if anyone knows it's you
what is the most complicated language to
learn Mandarin mystery solved
[Music]
you
three are not to be that is the question
whether tis nobler in the mind to suffer
the slings and I was a very just
fortunate consequent see him troubles
and by opposing end them to die to sleep
to sleep perchance to dream mother
you get micromachine man here presenting
a genuine written closely collectible
most micromachines a lot of people know
me as the micro machine man or the FedEx
guy or a terrible tester virgin from
Saved by the Bell or just that guy who
talks fast in fact I was in the Guinness
Book as the world's fastest talker and
so for the last 40 years have you needed
a fast talker I was your go-to guy is
that okay did you get everything you
need I mean I can repeat it again if you
want you sure you don't want to when I
was 12 years old I wanted to get into
the Guinness Book of World Records
so I figured the only thing I could
really do since I wasn't gonna eat a car
or swallow lead pipe was to lock myself
in a room and teach myself a stocking
and I did that with the hamlet soliloquy
years later I'm at this party fancy
California Beverly Hills party and a
friend of mine is trying to pick up this
valley girl he's from New York and
talking pretty quickly and she looks at
him and says look oh my gosh are you
like the world's fastest talker and he
says no as a matter of fact this person
is they called me overnight did one of
my little party routines because I come
up sipping a cup of tea but if I pick
typical difficult and a guy walked over
he says that's incredible I'm a producer
and I'm gonna put you on a show I went
on the show and I did the fast-talking
thinking that would be it and all of a
sudden the phone starts ringing and I'm
booked all over the place
and I managed to make a living out of it
I can speak as fast as eleven words a
second now I never do eleven words a
second for TV well let me do Peter Piper
at eleven words a second pick up to pick
up up to be back depicted because to
pick up a club depict then you kind of
hear me going pop pop pop but that's
really all you're kind of getting but
when you do TV there's visual
reinforcement people see you and do
whatever so I do about seven to eight
words a second that would sound
something like now on radio I have to do
it even a little slower because you have
no visual reinforcement you're not
seeing me so that I do about five to six
words a second so it sounds something
like and that's kind of the secret to my
success because if you can't understand
what I'm saying they're not gonna pay me
the big bucks now the very first
commercial I did was the Federal Express
commercial it is to this day the most
award-winning commercial in the history
of advertising the final scene I'm
sitting behind a desk and I'm going you
know Dave what's the deal with the deal
are we dealing David to deal with
Donovan to deal with dr. feelgood I'm
putting you down to deal with it so I
did the thing like 29 times
making a mistake and the director said
to me what are you like a machine you
never make a mistake I said you want to
miss sake I'll give you a mistake the
next time so I said David's a dork with
dick down and duck and that's the take
he ended up putting in the commercial
the first time I saw it I call this job
it's our little secret although I'm
known as the world's fastest talker I do
not choose to live by entire life in the
fast lane sometimes I just like to take
it all a little slower but sometimes
it's really really good to be test
you
[Music]
Mirek [ __ ] with us on no Sacchi ana hala
see another sake ERISA Kashi what those
characters are speaking isn't gibberish
it's actually a language called Dothraki
and it was invented by this guy David
Peterson in lovely Orange County
California David Peterson is what we
call a con Langer and inventor of
languages coddling is the intentional
creation of a full language creating its
full grammar it's full phonology it's a
writing system if it has one and its
entire lexicon david has written many
languages but the first one he wrote was
back in 2000 I was taking an intro
linguistics class at UC Berkeley in 2000
and it was just one day during class I
started scribbling on my no it's my very
first language he named it after his
girlfriend named Davey I'm according to
David himself it's irredeemably awful
it's just not it's not worth it even
considering anymore
everything I was doing with this
language was just a kind of really fancy
bizarre way to speak English so I kind
of just started over and said all right
Ground Zero how do I be a language
creator before we move forward let's
take a quick step back and talk about
the Godfather of modern commoning j.r.r
tolkien you probably know this name
because he's the author of The Hobbit
and Lord of the Rings
he created 14 different languages for
use within middle-earth Quenya and
Sindarin have probably his most famous
he was the very first person that we
know of to create languages just for fun
and we've been kind of emulating him
ever since now that we've cleared that
up we can move forward we're here in
California because we're curious about
what it takes to create a successful
language David's having two of his
friends who are also con langurs come
over and speak with us one of them
brought ice cream we were gonna do this
outside but it's too hot so we're gonna
do it inside
the three of them are talking about how
languages are created and they've come
up with five steps take it away guys oh
all right a naturalistic online means
five basic things one the people what
they do who their neighbors are the
second thing that you're going to need
is a phonology or sound system
do you have voiced and voiceless
consonants do you have aspirated
consonants three words all the nouns all
the verbs all the modifiers fourth
grammar which is the fun part
finally history you know how the
meanings of words changed over time and
you need to know how the grammar of your
language evolved from of time in the
distant past to what's used now now that
we've got that settled
let's finish this in the past 15 years
somebody who created language went from
somebody who was like oh you're a nerd
too you know
oh wow that's that's really nerdy which
now means cool and it's prolific use in
television and film proves that it's not
just a passing fancy for television the
difference between a created language
and some other set prop is that the
maximum level of interaction that a
viewer ever has with a background set or
with a prop is just seeing it on-screen
a language on the other hand when you
hear it that's the that's the most real
a language ever gets for that reason you
have to have a fully created language
for a television show and not just a
bunch of gibberish what's that good
thank God
[Music]